in the crypto world we hear a lot about
smart contracts but what are they and
how do they work smart contracts are
computer programs that run on the
blockchain picture a vending machine you
insert money push a button and get
something back there's no negotiation or
small talk the vending machine side of
the transaction is automated
programming responds to your inputs
smart contracts can be a bit like a
vending machine
or maybe they look like you and a friend
betting on a game or the price of ether
some smart contracts look more like
computer programs little autonomous
agents that execute a code when prompted
a lot of smart contracts run on the
ethereum blockchain which is a
distributed virtual computer
there are no keyboards or monitors just
thousands of computers running nodes of
the ethereum network your smart contract
will have all those computers verifying
that everything looks okay which takes a
little bit of time you wouldn't use this
sort of computer architecture for
anything like a self-driving car or
robot assisted surgery but this big
virtual computer does allow for
consensus there's agreement about what
happens on the network who sent money to
whom and what was executed when and
that's part of the magic check out the
crypto Story by Matt Levine for
Bloomberg businessweek
foreign